the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so since I know series decay is a
difficult topic to jump into I wanted to
quickly rego over the derivation today
and then specifically go over the case
of nuclear activation analysis which
reminds me did you guys bring in your
skin flakes and food pieces we have time
so if you didn't remember start thinking
about what you want to bring in what you
got okay so you've got aluminum foil you
want to see what in it is not aluminum
excellent what else did folks bring in
okay rubber stopper sound perfect
anyone else bring something in okay so
tell you what when you bring stuff in
bring it in a little plastic baggie I
can supply those if you don't have them
with your name on them just so we know
whose samples are what because that's
gonna be the basis for another one of
your homeworks when you're going to use
the stuff that we're learning today to
determine which impurities and how much
are in whatever thing that you looked at
and of course you're not going to get
all the impurities because in order to
do that we'd have to do a long nuclear
activation analysis or radiate for days
and count for a longer time so you'll
just be responsible for the isotopes on
the short list which we've posted on the
learning module site so again bring in
your whatever as long as it's not hair
because apparently that's a pain to deal
with or salty because the sodium
activates like crazy or fissionable
which you shouldn't have anyway I hope
none of you have fissionable material at
home so let's get let's get back into
series decay we very quickly went over
the definition of activity which is just
the decay constant times the amount of
stuff that there is the decay constants
and units of one over second the amount
of stuff let's call it a number density
could be like n atoms per centimeter
cubed for example so the activity would
give you the amount of let's say decays
per centimeter cubed per second if you
wanted to do this for an absolute amount
of a substance like you knew how much of
the substance there was you just ditch
the volume and you end up with that
activity in decays per second that unit
is better known as
girls or BQ named after Anjali Becca
though I don't know if I'm saying that
right but my wife's probably gonna yell
at me when she sees this video but said
BEC RL is simple it's simply one decay
per second and there's another unit
called the kiri which is just a whole
lot more decays per second it's a more
manageable unit of decays because Becker
the activity of many things in Becker
ELLs tends to be in the millions or
billions or trillions are much much more
for something that's really radioactive
and it gets annoying writing all the
zeros or all the scientific notation and
so last time we looked at a simple a
simple situation let's say you have some
isotope N 1 which decays with decay
constant lambda 1 to isotope n 2 which
decays with decay constant lambda 2 2 &
3 and we decided to set up our equations
in the form of change every one is just
a change equals a production - a
destruction for all cases so let's
forget the activation part for now we're
just going to assume that we have some
amount of isotope and one we'll say we
have n 1 naught at T equals zero and
it's a case - n 2 in the case 2 n 3 so
what are the differential equations
describing the rate of change of each of
these isotopes
so how about n1 is there any method of
production of isotope and one in this
scenario no we just started off with
some n1 but we do have destruction of n1
via radioactive decay and so the amount
of change is going to be equal to
negative the activity so for every decay
of n1 we lose an n1 atom so we just put
minus lambda 1 and 1 for every N 1 atom
that decays it produces an n2 so and 2
has an equal but different sign
production term and has a similar
looking destruction term meanwhile since
N 2 becomes n3 then we just have this
simple term right there and these are
the differential equations which we want
to solve we knew from last time that the
solution to this equation is pretty
simple
I'm not going to rego through the
derivation there since I think that's
kind of a easy one and and 3 we know is
pretty simple we used a conservation
equation to say that the total amount of
all atoms in this system has to be equal
to n 10 or n1 not so we know we have n
10 equals n1 plus n2 plus n3 for all
time so we don't really have to solve
for m3 because we can just deal with it
later the last thing that we need to
derive is what is the solution to end 2
and I want to correct a mistake that I
made because I'm gonna chalk that up to
exhaustion
assuming that integrating factor was
zero it's not zero so I want to show you
why it's not now so how did we go about
solving this what method did we use we
chose the integration factor method
because it's a nice clean one so we
rewrite this equation in terms of let's
just say n2 Prime let's see - I'm sorry
plus lambda 2 n2 minus lambda 1 n1 and
we don't necessarily want to
and n1 in there because we want to have
one variable only so instead of n 1 we
can substitute this whole thing in there
so n 10 e to the minus lambda 1 T equals
zero and let's just draw little thing
around here to help visually separate we
know how to solve this type of integrate
of this type of differential equation
because we can define some integrating
factor mu equals e to the minus whatever
is in front of the n2 that's not too
hard I'm sorry just e to the integral
not minus of lambda to DT we're just
equal to just e lambda 2 T and we
multiply every term in this equation by
mu because we're going to make sure that
the stuff here after we multiply by mu
and mu and mu and mu for completeness
that stuff in here should be something
that looks like the end of a product
rule so if we multiply that through we
get n 2 prime e to the lambda 2 T plus
let's see mu times lambda 2 e to the
lambda 2 T times n 2 minus e to the
lambda 2 T lambda 1 n 10 e to the minus
lambda 1 T equals 0 and indeed we've got
right here what looks like the end
result of the product rule where we have
something let's say one function times
the derivative of another plus the
derivative of that function times the
original other function so to compact
that up we can call that let's say n 2 e
to the lambda T lambda 1 and sorry
lambda 2 T prime minus and I'm gonna
combine these two exponents right here
so we'll have minus
lambda 1 + 10 e 2 thee let's see is it
lambda 2 minus lambda 1 T equals 0
just gonna take this term to the other
side of the equal sign so I'll just do
that integrate both sides and we get + 2
e to the lambda 2 T equals let's see
that'll be lambda 1 and 10 over lambda 2
minus lambda 1 times all that stuff I'm
gonna divide each side of the equation
by we'll use a different color for that
intermediate step e to the lambda 2 T
and that cancels these out that cancels
these out and I forgot that integrating
factor again didn't I
yeah so there's got to be a plus C
somewhere here and we're just going to
absorb this e to the lambda 2 t into
this integrating constant because it's
an integrating constant we haven't
defined it yet did someone have a
question I thought I saw okay and so now
this is where I went wrong last time
because I think I was exhausted and
commuted in from Columbus I just assumed
right away that C equals 0 but it's not
the case so if we plug in the condition
at T equals 0 + 2 should equal 0 let's
see what we get so that becomes that
would become a zero that T would be a
zero which means that we just end up
with the equation
lambda1 n 10 over lambda 2 minus lambda
1 plus c equals 0 so obviously the
integration constant is not like we
thought it was right
okay so then C equals negative that
stuff does that make more sense so you
guys see why the integrating constants
not 0 so in the end I'm going to skip
ahead a little of the math because I
want to get into nuclear activation
analysis we end up with and two should
equal let's see lambda 1 n 10 over
lambda 2 minus lambda 1 times did I
write that twice I think I did times e
to thee
let's see e to the minus lambda 1 t
minus e to the minus lambda 2 T and so
since we know N 1 we found N 2 we know n
free from this conservation equation
we've now fully determined what is the
concentration of every isotope in this
system for all time
and because the solution to this is not
that intuitive like I can't picture what
the function looks like in my head I
don't know about you guys
anyone know ok I did I can't either
I coded them up in this handy graphing
calculator
where you can play around with the I of
the concentration n 10 which is just a
multiplier for everything and the
relative half-lives lambda 1 and lambda
2 and I'll share this with you guys so
you can actually see generally how this
works so let's start looking at a couple
of cases move this a little over so we
can see the axes I'd say don't worry
about anything before T equals 0 that's
kind of an invalid part of the solution
so I'll just shrink us over there
and so I've coded up all three of these
equations there's the solution to n1
highlighted right there that's as you'd
expect simple exponential decay all N
one knows is that it's decaying
according to its own half-life or
exponential decay equation and two here
in the blue which expands of course
looks a little more complicated so what
we notice here is that n2 is tied
directly to the slope of n1 that should
follow pretty intuitively from the
differential equations because if you
look at the slope of n2 well it depends
directly on the value of n1 for very
very short times this is the sort of
limiting behavior and the and the
graphical guidance I want to give you to
solve questions like what's on the exam
or how to do a nuclear activation
analysis is everyone comfortable with me
hiding this board right here okay so
let's say at time is approximately zero
we know that there's going to be N 1 is
going to equal about n1 not what's the
value of n2 going to be very very close
to T equals zero zero so n2 is going to
equal zero but what's the slope of n2
going to be
this is how we can get started solving
these graphically without even knowing
what the real forms are so we've already
said that at a very short time n2 is
approximately zero so if that's zero
then that whole term is zero which means
that the slope of n 2 is approximately
lambda-1 n-1 just the activity of n1 and
hopefully that follows intuitively
because it says for really short times
before you get any build up the activity
or there sort of the what is it that the
slope of n1 determines the value of n2
so if we were to start graphing these
let's just start looking at some
limiting behavior that's T and we're
gonna need some colors for this let's
stick with the ones on the bore oh hey
awesome make n1 red and 2 blue and three
green so let's start drawing some
limiting behavior so we know that n1
starts here at n1 naught and we know
it's going to start decaying
exponentially so the slope here is just
going to be minus lambda1 and one which
is going to be the negative slope of n2
looks pretty similar doesn't it so we
know n2 for very short times is going to
start growing at the same rate that n1
is shrinking so we already know what
sort of direction these curves are
starting to go in how about n3 what's
the value of n3 for very short times
anyone just call it out
well we've got kind of a solution right
here if we know that n2 is about zero
for very short times what would the
value of n3 have to be also zero and
what about the slope of n3 also about
zero if there's no end to built up then
then there's nothing to create and three
so we know that our n3 curve is going to
start out pretty flat okay now how do we
find some other limiting behavior let's
now take the case let's see I want to
rewrite that a little closer here so we
have some room so that's at T equals
about zero and at T equals infinity what
sort of limiting behavior do you think
we'll have what's the value of n1 gonna
be at infinite time zero it will have
all decayed away will equal zero at t
equals infinity
how about n2 0 how about n3 and 1 not
correct because of that conservation
equation right here so we know for
limiting cases and 1 is going to be 0
and 2 is going to be 0 and in 3 it's
going to be n not so we've now filled in
all the four four corners of the graph
just intuitively without solving the
differential equations now let's start
to fill in some middle parts what other
sorts of things can we determine like
for example where n2 finds a Mac has a
maximum that shouldn't be too hard so
let's make another separation here so
what if we want to find out when does D
n2 DT equals 0
what do we do there
anyone have an idea using the equations
we have up here
yeah well we can just take this equation
right here we can figure that out in
terms of N 1 so if DN 2 DT equals 0 then
we know that lambda 1 N 1 is going to
equal lambda 2 n 2 what this says
intuitively is that the rate of
production of n 2 by decaying n 1 equals
the rate of destruction of n 2 by its
own decay so at some point the N twos
going to have to level off what that
when that point is depends on the
relative differences between those
half-lives so we already know if we were
to just kind of fill in smoothly what's
going to happen and two is probably
going to follow something roughly
looking like this we already know the
solution to N 1 I think we can figure
that out graphically it's simply
exponential decay the only trick now is
how does n 3 shape up what do you guys
think how would we go about graphically
plotting these solutions without solving
them because I haven't I don't think yet
I've given you the full form it's kind
of ugly and I doubt that if you looked
at it you'd be able to tell me exactly
what it would do so this is just the the
mathematical expression of n 10 minus N
1 minus n 2 so how do we figure out all
the stuff about n 3
same way as before we yeah absolutely
that's totally correct yeah if you just
take n ten minus N 1 minus n 2 that
gives you the value of n 3 that's
completely correct so you could do that
sort of one point at a time and say well
maybe around there maybe around there it
might take a little while though
so I want to think what's another
intuitive way what would the value of or
what would the value or the slope of n 3
track what other variable in the system
or in other words how are they directly
related yeah yeah the slope of n 3
depends directly on the value of n 2 and
nothing else so initially you can see
the value of n 2 is almost zero so the
slope of yeah so the slope of n 3 is
almost zero as the value of n 2 picks up
so should the slope of n 3 until we
reach here what happens at that point
yep the rate of production of n2
decreases cuz the Val I'm sorry that
yeah the rate of production of n3
decreases because the rate of production
of n3 is just dependent directly on the
value of n2 so thus maximum slope of n3
has to be right there at which point it
has to start leveling off and eventually
reaching zero you're gonna see this kind
of problem on the homework you're going
to see this kind of problem on the exam
I guarantee you but it's not going to
have this exact form but what I'll want
you to be able to do is follow this
example to say let's say I pose you a
small set of these first-order
differential equations can you use any
method that you want intuitive graphical
mathematical to predict what the values
and slopes of these isotopes are going
to be as a function of time so in order
to get nuclear activation analysis right
you need to be able to do this in
nuclear activation analysis it's just
one twist I'm gonna move this over to
add the twist you're also producing
isotope and one with a reaction rate by
some either isotope and not which you
put in the reactor so if you want to
know what your impurities and not work
to undergo what's called nuclear
activation analysis then you can figure
out depending on which one you count
what they could be so this right here
let's look at the units of this versus
the units of this a well first of all if
we're adding them together they'd better
be in the same units right so we already
talked about the units of this decay
equation it's like number of decays per
second so this reaction right here
better give us a number of atoms
produced per second or were kind of
messed up in the unit's so anyone
remember what is the units of let's see
you'll make a little extra piece right
here
what's the units of microscopic cross
section or barns
what is that in some sort of SI unit
yep it's like a centimeter squared and
what about flux this one I met you may
not know but it definitely depends on
the number of neutrons or the number of
particles that are there almost so the
flux describes how many particles pass
through a surface in a given time so we
have how many particles per unit surface
per unit time ends up being neutrons per
centimeter squared per second just like
the flux of photons through a space or
let's say the flux of any particle
through anywhere it describes how many
particles go through a space in a
certain time and then there's the number
of particles that are there if we're
going with atoms it's just let's say
atoms these are all multiplied together
the centimeters squared cancel and we
end up with some sort of a atoms per
second produced we can put in a little
hidden unit in the cross-section let's
say if there is a reaction going on
where in goes a neutron and out goes an
atom or something let's say that should
cancel all things out yeah let's not get
into that now
the whole point is we have the same sort
of unit going on here which is some
number of atoms produced per second same
thing as number of atoms decayed per
second
so it's the production destruction
equivalent of each other so in that way
we can have a reaction rate that we
impose something artificial by sticking
something in the reactor and controlling
its power level and then follow the
decay process which is a natural
radioactivity event and this is the one
of the simplest governing equations for
nuclear activation analysis now one I
might give this to you on an exam and
say ok now draw the curves for a nuclear
activation analysis and maybe calculate
what's the impurity level if you measure
this many counts of something then you
just work back through through the math
but I want to get you guys thinking
conceptually right now
what are the real equations for nuclear
activation analysis let's just do these
in terms of N 1 n 2 & 3
that's DT D + 3 DT I'll start with the
stuff that's up there
- lambda-1 n-1 plus some cross-section
times the flux times some other atom and
not what other things are we missing are
there any other methods of production or
destruction of isotope and one that we
need to consider well we've got isotope
n 1 in a reactor it can decay or it can
absorb one of the neutrons nearby so how
do we write that term that destruction
term yep
yeah so let's say that's the absorption
of atom 1 times n what did you say in it
would it be and not or would it be and 1
if you want to know how quick is n 1
being destroyed by absorbing neutrons so
then let's call this absorption of and
not and is it a plus or a minus if it's
a destruction rate it's a - yep so
what's really going on here is you've
got some precursor isotope whatever
impurity you want to measure and not
producing N 1 and you're looking at n
ones decay signature like it's activity
to determine how much was there but you
also have to account for the fact that
that isotope and 1 can be burned in the
reactor so this is like producing this
is decaying and this is we'll call it
being burned
this isn't burned in the sense of
creating of like fuel creating energy by
burning fuel but we will refer to this
sort of in its colloquially - burning
because we're then absorbing neutrons by
n1 and removing that from the available
decay signature
how about n2 how do we modify our
equation to account correctly for the
production and destruction of n2 and by
the way this is not in the book so I
don't expect you to just know it off the
top of your head
yeah so let's first take every term that
we have up there we have lambda 1 and 1
minus lambda 2 and 2 and what else do we
have to account for yep that's right so
n 2 is also being burned so we'll have a
- a flux times let's say the absorption
cross section 4 and 2 times the amount
of n - how about n 3 we'll start with
what we had there lambda 2 n 2 and just
like before we've got to account for the
burning of n 3 so then we'll have - flux
times the absorption cross section of 3
times n 3 and these equations hold true
only for the time that your materials in
the reactor what happens when you take
the material out of the reactor
you do yep when you come out of the
reactor all of the fluxes go to zero and
that's the end of that yeah
ah
so did I necessarily specify so the
question was why don't we account for
the production of n2 and n3 by the
burning right did we specify that
absorbing a neutron is the way to make
end - oftentimes it's not so if the
let's say if you burn and won by
absorbing a neutron then you will make
another isotope let's say that has the
same proton number and one more Neutron
and it may decay by some other crazy way
or it may be stable who knows but by
decay this could be by beta positron
alpha spontaneous fission not gamma then
you wouldn't have a different isotope
but oftentimes you won't have the
burning process won't produce the same
price otoki as the decay so the
situation we looked at on Friday when we
said let's escalate things that was a
purely hypothetical situation where
isotope n 2 could be burned to make n
zero last thing it can't happen but it's
not likely but still we can model it we
can model anything that just was in a
realistic situation this is this is what
you guys are going to have to look at to
understand how much impurities there are
in each of your materials so this I
would say this is the complete
description of nuclear activation
analysis in the reactor at which point
you then have to account for what
happens when you turn the reactor off so
well actually what physically happens
when you turn the reactor off
yep oh yeah let's even answer it a lot
so Chris yeah
[Music]
yep so normally to shut down the reactor
you'd put the control rods in and shut
down the reactor or the easier thing is
just pull the rabbit out remember those
little polyethylene tubes I showed you
this way we can keep the reactor on and
remove your samples without changing
anything so it makes the reactor folks
angry would be an understatement to
constantly change the power level of the
reactor reactor is especially power
reactors and research reactors they're
kind of like Mack trucks if they're
moving they want to stay moving and if
they're not moving they don't want to be
moving and it takes an awful lot of
effort to change that it also tap ins to
screw up experiments if you are
radiating something like I was a couple
months ago for 30 days you own it you
want to have a constant flux so that
your calculations are easy you don't
want 15 students to come in and turn the
knobs all up and down and then you have
to account for that in your data which
has happened so you guys are gonna be
manipulating the reactor power when the
experiments are out and it's at low
power so you won't be infuriating anyone
else on campus like we did last year cuz
I didn't account for that but they still
let us in so they're bad whatever yeah
so after you either shut down the
reactor or pull the rabbit out of the
reactor then the production and
destruction by neutrons is over but the
decay keeps going which means if you
wait too long like for some of those
short isotopes if you wait more than a
day or so you'll have so little activity
left that you won't be able to measure
it so what we're going to be doing is
sticking your samples into the reactor
for maybe an hour or so pulling them out
and immediately running them over to the
detector so that we get the most signal
per unit time because the things are
going to be the hottest when they come
right out of the reactor and every
second you lose from there you lose
signal which means you have to count for
longer to get the same amount of
information with the same certainty this
is a nice segue to what we'll be talking
about Thursday which is statistics
certainty and precision how long do you
have to count something to be confident
within some interval that you've got the
correct activity for background counts
if you who hears Mayday an NSC Geiger
counter
hopefully almost all of you maybe you
guys remember how long you had to count
to be 95% sure that your background rate
was accurate it ends up being about 67
minutes or over an hour and the reason
is because the count rate is very low so
I'll do a little flash forward to
Thursday since we're talking about it
when you count something with a very low
count rate you have to count for longer
to be as confident that your number is
correct so let's say you want to be 95%
confident or within plus or minus two
standard deviations or two Sigma you
have to count for longer and longer for
something that's really radioactive you
can be sure or 95% sure that the count
rate you measured is accurate for a
shorter counting time so everything in
this class seems to come up in
trade-offs right you trade-off stability
for a half-life you trade-off decay
constant for half-life you trade-off
binding energy for excess mass you
trade-off counting time and precision
you trade-off exposure and dose what
you're gonna get into later we'll see if
anyone wants to you know use a cell
phone or eat irradiated food afterwards
and I do all the time so that should
tell you the answer so in the last like
seven minutes or so I want to walk you
through playing around with what happens
when you change the values of lambda 1
and lambda 2 so what do they look like
when the half-lives are roughly equal
and when one is much larger than the
other one so let's set them to be about
equal these are just unitless so let's
set them equal to one I think the system
explodes when we set them exactly equal
because that term right there so let's
say that's 1.001
it's about as close as we can get and
let's confirm that we get the same sort
of behavior so isotope n 1 just follows
exponential decay there's nothing that
changes that isotope to its slope tracks
the value of isotope 1 for a little
while until you build up enough n 2 that
it starts to decay you can find when
that point is when lambda 1 N 1 equals
lambda 2 n 2 there's one little
stuff that we didn't fill in if you want
to find the value of n - so then you can
just rearrange this a little bit and
you'll say n - would have to equal
lambda 1 over lambda 2 x + 1 which is N
1 not e to the minus lambda 1 T so if
you want to find that point right there
in time you can solve this then let's
look at + 3 so n 3 when n 2 is almost 0
and 3 slope is almost zero it's a little
hard to see because so tell you what
let's make all the half-lives longer
which kind of expands the graph wrong
way let's see let's make it we'll just
move that decimal point point 1 there we
go that's like expanding the graph right
so when n 2 is almost 0 the slope of n 3
is almost 0 and when n 2 reaches a
maximum so does the slope of n 3 just
like we predicted using our graphical
method right here and then over longer
times let's put the half-lives back to
the way they were over long times and
three trends - and one not don't let
that little piece fool you again T
equals less than zero is not a valid
time for this so we're not accounting
for that and n 3 tracks right to your to
the value of n 1 not and n 2 and n 3
trend to 0 so for this case where you
have the half-lives roughly equal to
each other you can expect a pretty big
bump in n to what's going to happen when
lambda 1 is extraordinarily big meaning
the half-life of N 1 is extraordinarily
short what do you guys think will happen
not mathematically but physically if n1
just kind of goes boom and instantly
decays away yep your n1 is just gonna
turn into n2 right away and n2 is gonna
take its sweet time decaying to m3 so
let's see what that looks like if lambda
2 is much bigger than lambda 1 let's see
let's make the Maxima a little different
change our slider value a bit so if L 2
is big and L 1 is small well let me
change the actual axes to make this a
little easier to see there we go you can
see that much much more quickly than we
have it in this graph right here L 1
just decays away right away L I'm sorry
N one decays right away n 2 builds up to
a much higher relative value because
it's produced faster than its destroyed
for short amounts of time so you can end
up with a great spike in n2 which slowly
decays away to n3 how about the opposite
effect what if L 1 lambda 1 is really
really small indicating a very long
half-life and lambda 2 is really really
large indicating a small half-life yeah
that's right in this case you've got n2
as soon as its created self-destructs so
let's see what that looks like so we can
just slide l2 to be big slide l1 to be
small and you can actually graphically
see and to just shrink towards the
x-axis and it's almost like you only
have two equations it's like you just
have n1 and n3 and n2 basically doesn't
exist
where the slope of yeah where the slope
of n3 except that extremely short times
just tracks the value of n1 and I know
in the book they're called secular or
transient equilibria I'm not gonna
require that you memorize those terms
it's more important to me that I can
give you a real physical situation say
here's these three isotopes or four
isotopes or six it doesn't matter
because we can solve these pretty
quickly tell me what's gonna happen
based on their relative half-lives as
long as they decay in a nice linear
chain I'm not gonna give you something
where and one can be get and one or and
four or and six because at that point
you can construct the equations but I
don't expect you to be able to
graphically solve them and I may also
throw you curveballs like nuclear
activation analysis to see well what
happens when you turn on or turn off a
reactor I've got an example of that too
we're right at this point here I guess T
equals 50 yeah I've set it up such that
you turn off the reactor and let's say
m3 is stable right there but n1 and n2
continue to decay so it's not hard to
CAD these or to code these sorts of
things up I'll share the links with
these equations so you guys can play
with them yourselves add to them
yourselves and try just getting an
intuitive feel for how series
radioactive decay happens so I want to
know now that we spent a couple of days
on it would you guys be comfortable
setting up sets of differential
equations like this they say yes no
maybe I see a lot of up and down shaking
heads that's promising sign if not I'm
willing to spend a little more time in
it on Thursday folks in like a bit of
review
and if you're afraid to tell me just
send me an email and on of us or not yep
yeah I think so yeah with real example
with numbers and everything sure okay
well like we can make one of those up
for Thursday cool and what about the
graphical solution method since I don't
know whether they teach that in the G
IRS but what I do want you to be able to
do is look at the limiting cases in
other words fill in the four corners of
the graph at T equals zero what are
things actually doing and one is just
decaying at its half-life there's no end
to yet so these slopes are equal and
opposite and there's no n3 yet so that
there's no slope of n3 so I would like
you guys to try reproducing this and I
will again I'll provide pictures of
these blackboard so you guys can see but
it would be very helpful for you guys to
try to reproduce these graphs as we saw
them then you can check them here on the
graphical calculator and then play
around with the amount of n naught or I
think I just broke it let's just call
that one there we go
and play around with sliders or values
of N 1 & 2 or n 3 that's an interesting
solution yeah so since it's about four
of five of I want to open it up to any
questions you guys may have yeah
oh yeah I'll first the question is for a
spontaneous fission what fission
products do you choose I'll say they're
all good as long as as long as you pick
something with roughly equal ish masses
so you don't pick like it fizzes into
hydrogen and something swipes Mahler
which would be better known as just
proton emission you're gonna get roughly
the same answer yep roll at dat you'll
get you'll get basically the same result
rollin 80 sided dice hopefully at MIT
you could find one or write a program to
make a random number between you know
about 10 and 80 for 10 and 70 let's go
to the actual problem set to see what
you guys mean I want to make sure I'm
answering the correct question problem
statement yep yep so allowable this is
for this one allowable nuclear reactions
yep so for a spontaneous fission just
pick one you think of it would be likely
you can also look up what sort of
isotopes are created when elements fizz
it's not straight down the middle so
like uranium won't often split into two
equally sized fission products they'll
have roughly different masses but which
ones you pick you're still going to get
the same general solution yep
[Music]
so the question is when is spontaneous
fission possible is that only for heavy
elements there is a difference between
energetically possible and observed
that's part of the trick to this problem
is if you do out the Q equation to find
out for add the fission products that
you picked you may be surprised at the
result however you're right you don't
tend to see spontaneous fission happen
until you get to really heavy things
like uranium so there's more to will
something spontaneously fizz then is
that does the Q value allow it to happen
so I don't want to give away any more
but I will say if you're surprised at
your result you might be right yep yep
so how do we know which electron the
nucleus after do easier motion yep so
the question was if you're doing
electron capture where you have some
parent nucleus and you've got a lot of
electron shells the binding energy of
every electron is different which one
goes in one you find the data on the
NIST tables two chances are it will be
the closest one
so a roughly 80% of the time these
things happen from the K shell with very
decreasing probabilities from the outer
shells so you can pick either the K or
the L shell like both things may happen
but I would say for simplicity sake
assume it's an innermost shell electron
and you can look up the binding energy
on the NIST tables on the learning
module site so any other questions yeah
Luke
[Music]
for two yes so graphing the this would
be like if you had an electron detector
is that what I asked for for to write
the full nuclear reactions and draw the
energy spectrum you expect from eased
released form of radiation including
secondary ejections of particles or
photons so by a spectrum
I mean yup energy versus intensity so
there you'll have to account for the
spectrum like the various range of the
betas that can be released any ejected
electrons any RJ electrons any photons
from x-ray emission from electrons
falling down at energy levels yeah Alex
you had a question yeah the o'shea
electrons is that funny case where in
our mental model let's say a gamma ray
hits an inner shell electron and it's
usually an inner shell electron shooting
it out then another electron will fall
down to fill that hole emitting an x-ray
and the OJ process can be thought of
that second x-ray hits an electron on
the way out
and fires out the electron so this here
would be the oj electron they tend to be
particularly low-energy yeah Luke
[Music]
yeah as long as you have a higher level
shell coming down to a lower shell and
the ejection of an outer shell electron
that's the no J electron emission
process regardless of whether it started
with gamma or started with electron
capture yep you can actually sense or
detect the energy of those oj electrons
with a very sensitive Oh J electron
detector these are in the sort of
hundreds or thousands of evey range Oh
to get the Oh J electron data for that
you can actually look up the binding
energies of an outer shell electron and
you can do that energy balance where it
would be lets say e2 minus e1 whatever
the energy of that x-ray is minus the
binding energy of the emitted electron
and because there's infinite
possibilities I mean you could eject any
electron just pick one and say here's an
O J electron or draw a couple lines in
places I don't have I don't want you to
get every single line like if we ask you
to do this for uranium there's like you
know 92 electrons and a lot of different
transitions that's not what we're going
for I want to make sure you know the
physics not that you'd ruin draw 92
lines
accurately with a fine-toothed pencil
you know question 2
[Music]
the state which decay processes and
competing processes may be possible for
each general type of reaction maybe
that's the answer and does anything
compete with alpha decay does anything
compete with spontaneous fission okay
cool
beta decay well is there a lot for that
you can look up the table of nuclides
which I've got up here so let's take a
look at plutonium 239 and it proceeds by
yah alpha or spontaneous fission so
every year I switch up the isotope and
make sure that there's at least a couple
of decay modes and therefore the answers
are going to change every year but the
general question doesn't so this year I
happen to pick an interesting one yeah
it's kind of a mind game right what are
you missing nothing yeah yeah go with
your physical intuition any other
questions and maybe one time for one
more yeah mm-hmm
yep
yeah so the question is I specifically
wrote which nuclear reactions could make
99 molybdenum despite there being only
one natural one so what could you induce
artificially and if you can do that
profitably out guarantee you there's a
startup in it for you so what are all
the different particles that something
could absorb to create molybdenum-99 and
which of those are allowable nuclear
reactions and if they're not allowable
how much energy do you have to put in in
let's say an accelerator to make that
reaction happen and is the price of
electricity in the accelerator worth the
Molly 99 that you create they're
actually a few quite a few startups
working on this problem right now so the
answer to this question is be creative
think about all the different particles
you know of and how they could create
Molly 99 and figure out are any of those
processes allowed and if they're not
allowed how energetic do you have to
make the incoming particles to allow
them it's a good question there's some
creativity hiding in these problem sets
so it's 10:02 I want to cut it off here
and we'll start off Thursday with a word
numerical example of this stuff nuclear
activation analysis